now Selena wasn't done making headlines
today check out this major Revelation in
tonight's daily download hey guys we're
on set hey what are we shooting oh hi
there season three the only murders in
the building gang are back and growing
in numbers and Oscar winners could this
honestly get any better uh
well I do think it could get a little
bit better why
yeah oh please thank you thank you ma'am
that's right it's only Legends in the
building with Meryl Streep joining
season three and the cast can't hide
their excitement I've already had a
community uh just the tea that I'd asked
for a half an hour ago I'm okay pretty
sweet
well we're on the topic of Legends
please welcome amazing to the view the
incomparable Dolly Parton
if I'm going to be in the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame I'm gonna have to do
something to Ernie so I'm doing a rock
and roll album and I'm having a lot of
the rock stars that I met that night
beyond the album with me yes dolly is
dishing all the details on her upcoming
rock album With a Little Help from her
famous friends you do go way back with
Mick Jagger any chance of getting him to
record with you oh well I'm doing my
best to try to get him on so it's a
maybe for Mick but it's a yes for Paul
McCartney pink Stevie Nicks and more
plus Dolly's been working nine to five
with a pop icon
[Music]
I'm even gonna have share on I've been
you know getting a song for her we've
been trying to get the right thing
together but that's going to be a big a
big thrill and Jeremy Renner is giving
us a health update following the snow
plow accident that left him in critical
condition however this update is from
the comfort of his own home and not the
hospital he shared the news on Twitter
letting fans know he was watching season
two of his crime drama mayor of
Kingstown writing outside my brain fog
in recovery I was very excited to watch
episode 201 with my family at home